TONIGHT FROM THE TRUMP HOTEL
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT PICTURES
BUT, FIRST, WASHINGTON HAS
BEEN IN NEAR LIMBO ALL DAY.
MESMERIZED BY THE PROMISE
THAT THE NOW FAMOUS HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MEMO
ANY SECOND.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN IT TURNS
OUT.
AT THIS POINT ALL WE KNOW
FOR CERTAIN ABOUT THE MEMO
IS THAT IT'S FOUR PAGES
LONG.
IT WAS COMPILED BY INTEL
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN DEVIN
NUNES AND AS OF TONIGHT
REMAINS CLASSIFIED AND
HIDDEN FROM PUBLIC VIEW.
ACCORDING TO SOME WHO HAVE
READ IT THE MEMO EXPOSES
SHOCKING MISCONDUCT BY
INTELLIGENCE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DURING
THE 2016 ELECTION.
INCLUDING SPYING ON
AMERICANS FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES.
WE CAN'T CONFIRM ANY OF
THAT.
LIKE PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE
ELSE, WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
DOCUMENT.
BUFF THE CHARGES ARE STRONG
ENOUGH TO SHAKE PUBLIC FAITH
IN SOME OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT PUBLIC
IS TO RELEASE THE MEMO SO
THE REST OF US CAN SEE THE
EVIDENCE AND DECIDE FOR
OURSELVES WHAT IT AMOUNTS
TO.
THAT'S HOW DEMOCRACIES WORK.
IT SEEMS LIKE AN OBVIOUS
SOLUTION.
IN FACT, IT'S THE ONLY
AND, YET, FOR SOME REASON,
THE PROSPECT OF TRANSPARENCY
HAS TRIGGERED PANIC IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND AMONG
ITS GUARD IN THE MEDIA.
JUST A YEAR AGO "THE
WASHINGTON POST," FOR
EXAMPLE, ADOPTED THE POMP
POSE AND YET INDISPUTABLE
TRUE SLOGAN DEMOCRACY DIES
IN DARKNESS.
MEMO AS, QUOTE, A HYPER
PARTISAN ATTEMPT TO
DISCREDIT MUELLER.
OF COURSE, THE POST WOULD
HAVE NO WAY OF KNOWING THAT
THEY HAVEN'T SEEN THE MEMO.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE
IT, EITHER.
HOW DID DEMOCRACY DIES IN
DARKNESS BECOME SOME THINGS
TRANSPARENCY HURTS
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA OPPOSE
TRANSAPPARENTLY REMEMBER
WHEN CNN'S CHRIS CUOMO
WARNED VIEWERS THEY WOULD BE
BREAKING THE LAW SIMPLY BY
READING JOHN PODESTA'S
THIS.
AS THE ONION PUT IT TOGETHER
THE FBI WARNS REPUBLICAN
MEMO COULD UNDERMINE FAITH
IN MASSIVE UNACCOUNTABLE
SECRET GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
WOULD RATHER AVOID
ACCOUNTABILITY IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
TRANSPARENCY CAUCUS HAS
ALWAYS BEEN NOTABLY SMALL.
THE QUESTION IS ARE THERE
REASONS CRAVEN FOR CHEERING
DEMOCRATS OR CAREER
COME TO MIND.
ARE THE CONTENTS OF THE MEMO
PROVABLABLY FALSE AND WOULD
RELEASING THE MEMO IMPERIL
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THOSE ARE REALENS QUESTIONS.
SO FAR THE ANSWER TO BOTH
APPEARS TO BE NO.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE IS NO
EXCUSE FOR WITHHOLDING THIS
DOCUMENT FROM THE PUBLIC,